David Tennant is one of the most beloved actors
around, with acclaimed turns as The Doctor
and Detective Alec Hardy on "Broadchurch." So
why haven't you heard from him lately? It isn't
like he's stopped working. He has stayed pretty
busy, but with projects you may not have seen.
Don't get us wrong, we're not here to judge. In
fact, if the only TV show you regularly watch or
pay attention to is "Doctor Who," you might
be doing something right. Launched in 1963,
the ongoing adventure of the time and
space-traveling do-gooder known as the
Doctor remains an intensely influential sci-fi
institution. In part, this is by virtue of
having existed for so long. If a person feels like
watching "Doctor Who" and absolutely nothing else,
that person could certainly manage that
without boredom ever presenting itself as
a major problem. Tennant's three seasons
alone could tide one over for a while.
Tennant's Tenth Doctor appears in at least two
of the best "Doctor Who" episodes of all time:
"Blink" and "The Girl In The Fireplace." His
run didn't just wow fans — it reinvigorated
"Doctor Who" as a whole. So if this is
still what you know Tennant best for,
well, you've got taste. But if it
is, in fact, your preference to watch
nothing except "Doctor Who," it explains why
you haven't heard from the man in a while,
as he hasn't regularly been on that
show since President Obama's first term.
"Don't be ridiculous."
We should clarify that when we
say David Tennant does not appear
regularly on "Doctor Who," we're referring to the
BBC television program. But while his time as a
physical presence on the TARDIS ended in 2010,
his time as the Doctor continues to this day.
The Tenth Doctor joins forces with Tom Baker's
indispensable Fourth Doctor, with their original
actors voicing both characters, in the audio
drama "Out Of Time," released in August 2020.
This is enormously exciting for fans: The Fourth
Doctor, who Baker portrayed from 1974 to 1981,
still stands as one of the most
widely-recognized versions of the character.
But this production is actually not all
that out of the ordinary for Tennant,
who records Doctor Who audio dramas all the time.
In fact, it just so happens that "Doctor
Who" related projects only comprise a
fraction of Tennant's extensive audio drama
and audio book catalog. His participation
in audio "Who" actually dates back to before
Christopher Eccleston rebooted the role in 2005:
Tennant played a non-leading part
in 2001's "Doctor Who: Colditz,"
a story involving Nazis who somehow gain access
to the TARDIS at the conclusion of World War II.
"Doctor Who" has not yet produced a video game
major crossover success just yet. But just
like James Bond, Marvel Comics, and other major
franchises with similar longevity, the beloved
series has been churning out video games for
pretty much as long as video games have existed.
This brings us to "Doctor Who: The Edge
of Reality." The game's official website
describes "Edge of Reality" as a reimagining
of 2019's "Doctor Who: The Edge of Time,"
a VR game for console and PC. Where "Edge of
Time" features the Thirteenth Doctor played
by Jodie Whittaker, "Reality" includes both
her and David Tennant as the Tenth Doctor.
According to the game's official website,
Edge of Reality will see the Doctors address
a threat to all of reality. It pits the
player against Daleks, Weeping Angels,
Cybermen, and various lesser-known but
equally-deadly intergalactic baddies.
As far as Tennant goes, it's basically
a continuation of his already extensive
catalogue of Who-related voiceover
work. But the jump from audio books
to games is significant for his fans —
you can't play an audio book, after all.
"You need my voice in particular.
The cleverest voice in the room."
Everybody's got a podcast these days,
including our man David Tennant. His
podcast, featuring the uninspiring name
"David Tennant Does A Podcast With…" began in
2019 and has been running every week since.
This series of hour-long conversations
with Tennant's fellow famous people
is a delightful project for
Tennant fans of all stripes.
Notable guests include US politician and
activist Stacey Abrams, author Neil Gaiman,
actress Elisabeth Moss, former "Doctor
Who" star Billie Piper, and many others.
Unsurprisingly, Tennant's got a knack
for cultivating engaging discourse.
"David Tennant Does A Podcast With…"
plays out in roughly the same playful
spirit as Marc Maron's "WTF:" the host
and guest take a seemingly unscripted,
casual journey through the latter's life, career,
ideas, attitudes, and anecdotes, plus any other
subjects they stumble into. Tennant hasn't been
in the podcasting game for as long as Maron, or
many other well-known podcast hosts with a
similar sensibility. But Tennant makes up for
his lack of experience with his easygoing nature,
disarming charm, and engaging Scottish accent.
By no means did David Tennant drop off of
television after "Doctor Who." In fact,
for certain demographics, Doctor Who might not
even be the program for which he's most famous.
David Tennant voiced the lead role on "DuckTales,"
a celebrated reboot of the
1987 cartoon of the same name.
If you've seen "DuckTales" in its modern
incarnation and didn't recognize David
Tennant, you don't need to feel like a dumb-dumb:
he appears in the role of the
billionaire mallard Scrooge McDuck.
The reboot has been met with an abundance
of praise – a major feat in any case,
but especially impressive when
one considers the fact that people
love the '80s "DuckTales" series. At the risk
of blasphemy, we're going to go ahead and say
the new DuckTales doesn't just earn that praise
... it might surpass the original cartoon. The
humor and storytelling can keep adults in the
room interested without alienating any kids,
the cast is star-studded, and, most importantly,
Huey, Dewey, and Louie don't emulate their
Uncle Donald's unintelligible squawking.
Instead, Donald's nephews sound like the
famous comedians who do their voices.
That is a seriously major improvement.
"I promise I won't let anything bad happen to ya."
The miniseries "Good Omens," starring the one
and only David Tennant, burst onto Amazon Prime
in May of 2019. Based on the 1990 Neil Gaiman
and Terry Pratchett novel of the same name,
"Good Omens" involves a demon played by Tennant,
an angel played by Michael Sheen, their unlikely
friendship, and various factors pertaining to the
biblical end of all life in the universe. The cast
also includes John Hamm, Miranda Richardson,
and Frances McDormand, who portrays God.
While "Good Omens" is not as culturally prevalent
as some of Tennant's other work, it was a slam
dunk in terms of quality: Critics almost all
got a real kick out of it. Meanwhile, author
Neil Gaiman has said he found the experience of
making the series wildly educational, especially
in regards to his professional transition from
full-time wordsmith to television showrunner.
In a roundabout way, that means we have
David Tennant to thank for whatever success
is enjoyed by Netflix's "Sandman" series, on
which Gaiman serves as executive producer.
During the COVID-19 pandemic, people discovered
all kinds of awesome activities you can do
without going outside. You can watch movies.
You can watch television. You can read books.
You can play board games ... and that's pretty
much everything. As for things you can't do?
Well, you can't film a television series
about traveling the circumference of the
world in a hot-air balloon.
If that's your objective,
you're going to have to wait until the pandemic
is over, or at least has subsided significantly.
The eight-episode limited series
"Around The World in 80 Days" took
a pandemic-mandated production pause back in
March 2020 and resumed shooting in November.
This TV adaptation of the 1872 novel by
Jules Verne stars Tennant as Phileas Fogg,
the gambling protagonist, appearing alongside
Leonie Benesch as Detective Fix and Ibrahim Koma
as Passepartout. It looks to be a whimsical
and exciting updating of the classic story,
and the talent in the main ensemble is
seriously impressive. It releases in late 2021.
There's a pretty significant problem with
our collective preoccupation with major
streaming platforms. Namely, if anything
cool or interesting comes out on one of
the lesser-known services, we might not
find out about it until months later.
So if you didn't notice David Tennant's
turn as convicted serial killer and really,
really creepy dude Dennis Nilsen, we can't
blame you: the three-part 2020 series "Des"
is available on the little-known platform
Sundance Now. It's well worth seeking out,
however, even if it does mean signing up for yet
another streaming service. The searing drama got
some pretty positive feedback, with Tennant's
performance praised as his most unsettling and
upsetting to date. Keep in mind, one of Tennant's
most famous roles happens to be Kilgrave,
a homicidal abuser with mind-control powers.
Still, the critics urge us to believe that
next to his depiction of Nilsen, Kilgrave comes
off as well-adjusted and socially acceptable.
We shouldn't define Tennant's career, or
even judge his artistic instincts, based
on a handful of roles cherry-picked off a CV that
has been steadily expanding since 1988, of course.
But it is a pretty funny coincidence that
we recognize him primarily as either a
happy-go-lucky fantasy character like
the Doctor or Scrooge McDuck ... or as a
homicidal sociopath like Nilsen or Kilgrave.
The public seems to prefer David Tennant as
one extreme or the other – and it seems he
likes taking those over-the-top roles, too.
The Coronavirus pandemic had a disastrous effect
on every industry, including the entertainment
industry. Massive delays were put on several
productions in order to help stop the spread
of the disease, and it was a difficult situation
to try to adapt to and film around. Thus, it isn't
exactly surprising that we didn't get a ton of
notable pandemic films or TV shows either — but
a few did make it out of creative brains and into
existence. "Staged" is a perfect example of this.
"Staged" stars David Tennant and his "Good
Omens" co-star Michael Sheen as exaggerated
versions of themselves. That's right: this is
one of those fictionalized-real-people affairs,
a la Keanu Reeves in "Always Be My Maybe."
"It's called Vice Breaker. It's like truth
or dare, but a little more apocalyptic."
In "Staged," Tennant and Sheen are set to star in
a production of "Six Characters in Search of an
Author" by Luigi Pirandello, but the production
faces an indefinite delay due to the pandemic
lockdown of pretty much every stage in Europe.
The pair of actors decide to rehearse and cast
the play over Zoom. As viewing experiences go,
Staged resonates like a digital, British version
of "Curb Your Enthusiasm." Check it out, and we'd
encourage you to go in without doing too much
reading about it: there are some incredible
guest appearances that are great surprises.
The disappointing fate of Marvel's first attempt
at putting the Marvel Cinematic Universe on
streaming television has been well documented.
As a result, it's easy to forget there was a
time when Kevin Feige would've been crazy to act
like Netflix's Marvel output didn't count as canon
MCU material. The first season of "Jessica
Jones" was particularly well received, and
Tennant deserves significant credit for this turn
of events. Let us not forget that back in 2015,
the only MCU villains anyone considered worth a
darn were Loki, fellow Netflix baddie Wilson Fisk,
and Tennant's Kilgrave, oft-referred
to in the comics as the Purple Man.
As Kilgrave, Tennant inverts the quirky
charm he wields as the Doctor and stuffs
it into a sociopath that Jessica Jones combats
throughout the latter two-thirds of the season.
Kilgrave ceases to be a series regular
following the initial 13 episodes, however,
and while we'd like to make a case that
Kilgrave's exit doesn't serve the show's
larger story and other characters, we can't.
Despite the quality of Tennant's performance,
"Jessica Jones" made the right call in
keeping Kilgrave out of its second season.
But, in an alternate-universe scenario where the
folks in charge of the MCU decided to do more
stuff with Kilgrave, Marvel fans would probably
be talking about David Tennant more often. And
we've seen comic book characters come back from
worse, so we've still got our fingers crossed!
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.